okay our next speaker is the kind of
politician that has the political
courage to stand up and speak to what he
believes in he's running for congress in
in North Carolina his name is Ario
Pantano he's a veteran and he's a man of
courage and we need more of him so let's
bring up Ario
Pantano big round of applause please
simpy Marines
simpy ladies and gentlemen I'm not here
today as a candidate I'm here today as a
Survivor and a victim just like all of
you but more importantly I'm here as an
american ladies and gentlemen I want you
to look around look around take a moment
and acknowledge yourself there were
people at the airport my family and I
flew in today from North Carolina there
were people who flew in from London
England ladies and gentlemen if you
traveled to get here today would you
raise your hand we can acknowledge you
look around
folks and while we're at
it if you're a veteran if you've served
this country in the armed forces or in a
uniform of the firefighters or Police
Department emergency responders would
you please raise your hand so we can
acknowledge
you folks I'm just here to very quickly
tell you a little 911 story and then I'm
going to tell you my opinion about this
mosque my 911 story started about 20
years ago I was a marine sniper in
Israel the first Gulf War was over
and some Israeli soldiers said to me why
are you thousands of miles away from
your home this was in
1992 and I was a 22-year-old young
marine and cocky and I said well I'm
here fighting in your backyard so we
don't have to be fighting in our
backyard ladies and gentlemen what I
would be going to work just up Fifth
Avenue one
morning watching the buildings burn burn
wondering why the fire engines were
screaming down Fifth
Avenue all the Avenues all the
Avenues like all of you I knew that our
world had changed
forever and 10 years after I had been a
Marine in the first
war I showed up at my doorstep and my
poor wife who's here today listening saw
that I had shaved my head and I was
going back into the Marines a second
time to fight for America
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I wasn't alone
there were millions of men and women
just like us who in some form or fashion
took up arms took up the flag did what
they could where they could whether they
volunteered here whether they
volunteered
overseas whether they prayed or they
fought America was United and I'm going
to hold this up I don't know if any of
you can see this but this is an aerial
photo of ground
zero and some of the men in my unit made
this for me and I carried it next to my
heart inside my Flack jacket when I was
in
Iraq and
I'll no ladies and gentlemen the message
here what's important here is the words
on the top say never
forget never
forget let's fast forward to today I'm
in North Carolina made that my home I
love the values they love God they love
America we fight for what we believe in
and I had a news reporter asked me why
do you care about a mosque in ground
zero you're down in North
Carolina I said brother on September
11th it wasn't New York City that was
attacked it was America that was
attacked it was Freedom that was
attacked and we can't forget not only
what happened not only the murderous
intent that killed 3,000 Americans we
can't forget for a moment that they
wanted to kill 50,000 Americans or maybe
a
100,000 Americans so we can't ever
forget that murderous intent and you
know what else we can't forget because
we have folks we've
forgotten nine years later we've gotten
complacent and we've forgotten but since
those attacks hundreds of thousands of
men and women around the world have been
killed by jihadists in the name of
radical Islam hundreds of of thousands
of men and women around the
world from Egypt to Bali from Baghdad to
Cabell no one can forget there was a car
bomb here in Time Square just months ago
folks if you think this is over it's
just
beginning it's just
beginning so now we get to the next part
so what's my opinion about a mosque at
Ground
Zero no mosque here
no mosque
here no mosque
here I've heard I've heard some of the
some of the folks in the media on the
left and they're so smart and they're so
smug well it's not even at Ground Zero
ladies and gentlemen look around look
around if you were standing on the roof
of the building you would have been
killed by a piece of landing gear off of
an aircraft that was piloted by
terrorists who had just slit the throats
of unarmed stewardesses and Pilots
ladies and gentlemen this is Ground
Zero so let's take a moment to look at
the person that wants to bring it here
does anyone find it's interesting that
he's also involved in the free Gaza
flotilla movement that had a made for TV
action with Israel just as all of this
was developing but there was something
else that happened because and I want to
stretch your imagination for a second
but every time Iran is about to face a
nuclear sanction from the EU or the UN
what
happens something flares up with
Israel I wonder how that happens I
wonder in 2006 when Iran was about to
face nuclear nuclear sanctions for their
nuclear weapons program yes folks we
want to give radical extremist nuclear
weapons it's unconscionable to me but
remember back to 2006 a fight in Lebanon
with the
Israelis who provoked that
Iran Iran think back to 2008 again Iran
about to face sanctions who provoked
attacks from Gaza missile attacks into
Israel
Iran and radical Islam
that's exactly
right ladies and gentlemen in 2010 as
Iran faced its toughest rounds of
sanction we had this made for TV episode
when Israel rightfully trying to protect
itself by maintaining a blockade to make
sure murderous Rockets don't kill its
innocent
citizens where did that come from Imam
rouf is a member of the organization
that has been behind all of that we know
that Iran has been complicit in all of
that I want to know where the money for
this
is coming
from ladies and gentlemen I'm going to
close with some words from a president
that we know and love his name is Ronald
Reagan and he talked about a time he
talked about a time when America would
have a Rendevous with Destiny it's
happening right here at Ground Zero
we've had one here before we're having
it again it's up to you
ladies and gentlemen it's up to you and
you know that mayor Rudy Giuliani made
an excellent point recently and he said
if this mosque is really about building
bridges and these folks are about
healing then they're going to hear this
message and they're going to move
they're going to move the right thing
and they're going to
move but if they're
Warriors if they're Warriors they're
going to dig in and they're going to
stay well you you know what we have
Warriors
too God bless America